[Music]
your internship in professor Ramsey's
physics lab has been amazing until that
is the professor accidentally stepped
through a time portal you've got just a
minute to jump through the portal to
save him before it closes and leaves him
stranded in history once you're through
it the portal will close and your only
way back will be to create a new one
using the chrono nodules from your lab
activated nodules connect to each other
via red or blue tachyon entanglement
activate more nodules and they'll
connect to all other nodules in the area
as soon as a red or blue triangle is
created with a nodule at each point it
opens a doorway through time that will
take you back to the present but the
color of each individual connection
manifests at random and there's no way
to choose or change its color and
there's one more problem each individual
nodule creates a temporal instability
that raises the chances the portal might
collapse as you go through it so the
fewer you bring the better the portal is
about to close what's the minimum number
of nodules you need to bring to be
certain you'll create a red or blue
triangle and get back to the present
[Music]
this question is so rich that an entire
branch of mathematics known as a Ramsey
theory developed from it Ramsey theory
is home to some famously difficult
problems this one isn't easy but it can
be handled if you approach it
systematically imagine you brought just
three modules would that be enough no
for example you might have two blue and
one red connection and be stuck in the
past forever would four nodules be
enough no there are many arrangements
here that don't give a blue or red
triangle what about five it turns out
there is an arrangement of connections
that avoids creating a blue or red
triangle if these smaller triangles
don't count because they don't have a
nodule at each corner however six
nodules will always create a blue
triangle or a red triangle here's how we
can prove that without sorting through
every possible case imagine activating
the sixth nodule and consider how it
might connect to the other five it could
do so in one of six ways with five red
connections
five blue connections or some mix of red
and blue notice that every possibility
has at least three connections of the
same color coming from this nodule let's
look at just the nodules on the other
end of those same three color
connections if the connections were blue
then any additional blue connection
between those three would give us a blue
triangle so the only way we could get in
trouble is if all the connections
between them were red but those three
red connections would give us a red
triangle no matter what happens we'll
get a red or a blue triangle and open
our door way on the other hand if the
original three connections were all red
instead of blue the same argument still
works with all the colors flipped in
other words no matter how the
connections are colored six nodules will
always create a red
triangle and a doorway leading home so
you've grabbed six nodules and jumped
through the portal you were hoping your
internship would give you valuable life
experience turns out that didn't take
much time a given triangular time portal
can only transport one person before it
closes with these six chrono nodules
will two portals always form or could
one of you be stranded in history this
bonus riddle comes courtesy of our
sponsor brilliant they start with simple
questions that build your intuition ramp
up to puzzles that entice you and then
help you develop ways of solving
problems that were previously out of
your grasp to hone your capacity to
think critically visit brilliant org
slash ted-ed the first 833 of you to use
that link will get a 20% discount off
the annual subscription